SECRETARY OF POLICE CALLED THE
ROLL. ALAN OVERALL GULL.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD. CERRO
CORTESI. DALLY. DODD DO RAZO,
EGM GLAZER, GONZALEZ GROVE TAO.
JONES LAIRD, LIMÓN MAGUIRE.
MINIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN. WHEN NELO
OCHO PUM ORO. ROTH. RUBIO,
SEYARTO SKINNER. SMALL QUAVERS
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB WIENER.
WILK. MEMBERS OF QU IS PRESENT
WITH OUR MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
BEYOND THE REALM AND IN THE
GALLERY, PLEASE RISE. WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
BARMAN, AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. AND LET US BRING
OURSELVES INTO THE PRESENCE OF
GOD AND EACH OTHER. AND TODAY WE
PRAY WITH A MARY OLIVER POEM
CALLED PRAYING. IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE THE BLUE IRIS. IT COULD BE
WEEDS IN A VACANT LOT. OR A FEW
SMALL STONES. JUST PAY
ATTENTION. THEN PATCH A FEW
WORDS TOGETHER. AND DON'T TRY TO
MAKE THEM ELABORATE. THIS IS NOT
A CONTEST. BUT THE DOORWAY INTO
THANKS AND A SILENCE. IN WHICH
ANOTHER VOICE MAY SPEAK. I'D
LIKE TO READ IT AGAIN AND INVITE
YOU TO A FEW MOMENTS OF SILENCE.
SO THAT YOU CAN HEAR THE PRAYER
THAT GOD IS PRAYING IN YOU
TODAY. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THE
BLUE IRIS. IT COULD BE WEEDS IN
A VACANT LOT. OR A FEW SMALL
STONES. JUST PAY ATTENTION. THEN
PATCH A FEW WORDS TOGETHER. AND
DON'T TRY TO MAKE THEM
ELABORATE. THIS IS NOT A
CONTEST. BUT THE DOORWAY INTO
THANKS AND A SILENCE. IN WHICH
ANOTHER VOICE MAY SPEAK.
AMEN. MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
PRO TEM MCGUIRE. YOU RECOGNIZE?
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR PRESIDENT,
GRATEFUL AND SISTER MICHELLE,
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL. UH, MEMBERS
JOINING US IN THE GALLERY IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A NATIONAL
PUBLIC HEALTH WEEK OR SOME
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE, MEMBERS OF
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION, THEIR PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTORS, THEIR COUNTY AND CITY
HEALTH DIRECTORS, AND THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO KEEPING THIS STATE
HEALTHY AND MORE THAN EVER
COMING OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC. WE
NEED TO SAY THANK YOU TO PUBLIC
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE THEM A WARM
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. SENATOR WEINER. THANK
YOU. OH, OUR MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
I. I AM SORRY. I AM SORRY PAGES
GOT STUCK. ALL RIGHT. FIRST
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES, SENATOR WEER. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT, UM COLLEAGUES
. I MOVE ADOPTION OF AUTHORS.
AMENDMENTS FOR ASSEMBLY BILLS,
106 AND 144. BUDGET BILLS, UH,
CROSS THE DESK ON FRIDAY,
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY, APRIL 5TH
THROUGH 7TH 2024. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED,
PUBLISHED AND THE BILLS RETURNED
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR NEEDLE PURPOSE. TO SPEAK
TO THE MOTION. GO RIGHT AHEAD
FLOORS. UM I'M SURE NONE OF YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA SAY. WHAT A
MYSTERY. BUT UH, I AM GONNA SAY
A LITTLE BIT MORE. BECAUSE
COUPLE WEEKS AGO, WE HAD THE
DOCUMENT SHRINK THE SHORTFALL.
UH, THAT WAS THE UH, SENATE
DEMOCRATS PROPOSAL TO SHRINK THE
SHORTFALL. UH AND THEN
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT A SUPPOSED
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR
TO, UH, PLUG SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
12 AND $17 BILLION OF THE
EXISTING BUDGET DEFICIT. WITH NÓ
DETAIL. UH AND THEN, UH, JUST,
UH, THIS WEEK, THE ASSEMBLY
COMES OUT WITH A PROPOSAL. UH,
WITHOUT MUCH DETAIL. AND, UH SO
UH, WE'RE WE CERTAINLY WAIT FOR
MORE DETAIL FROM THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS, BUT ONE PROBLEM IS
OUR CAUCUS. HAS ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING. TO DO WITH IT. AND THE
REAL RISK IS THAT THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUES TO MAINTAIN THAT THIS
BUDGET DEFICIT IS $38 BILLION.
UH, WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT, UH 17
OR 18 BILLION PLUGS ABOUT HALF
OF THE DEFICIT THAT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE WE HAVE ALL THAT BIG A
PROBLEM TO SOLVE IN, UH 2004 THE
2004 5 BUDGET. UM, WHICH IS AN
ILLUSION. AND MAYBE THAT'S WHY
WE'RE, UH, TAKING SO LONG. BUT
UM, FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, WE
LEARN ALL OF THESE THINGS. UM
LATER ON AT ABOUT THE SAME TIME
AS OUR 8 MILLION CONSTITUENTS.
LEARN IT. THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THIS PROCESS
VERSUS MY PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE, I
HAVE TO SAY IS SOMEWHAT
FRUSTRATING. AND UH, JUST
CONTRARY TO THE COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS THAT THIS VERY WONDERFUL
COLLABORATIVE BODY SHOULD HAVE
AND SO, UH, HERE AGAIN. UH, WERE
AUTHORIZING OVER THE DARK OF
WEEKEND? UH WORK ON BUDGET BILLS
, UH, THAT WE WILL LEARN ABOUT
ALSO, AND ABOUT THE SAME TIME AS
OUR 8 MILLION CONSTITUENTS DO. I
URGE A NÓ VOTE. I HEARD WINNER.
SOONER WINTER'S ASKING FOR I
VOTE. SENATOR NEIL WAS ASKING
FOR NÓ VOTE SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. UH, SENATOR, ALL
RIGHT. YOU WANNA CLOSE? YEAH UH,
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH, I
APPRECIATE THE REMARKS OF THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE, UH, OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE. UH, JUST TO BE
CLEAR WHEN, UH, WHEN WE RELEASED
THE SHRINK THE SHORTFALL, UH,
PLAN OF ABOUT $17 BILLION IN
EARLY ACTIONS TO REDUCE QUICKLY
THE SIZE OF THE DEFICIT. UH, WE
WERE INCREDIBLY TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THAT THAT'S BEEN OUT IN
THE PUBLIC HEAVILY DISCUSSED. UH
THIS BILL WILL GO INTO PRINT.
AND THEN THERE WILL BE FURTHER
DISCUSSION. UH, WE HAVE OUR 72
HOURS RULE. WE WILL HAVE A
HEARING. UH AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD. UH, I ALSO JUST
WANT TO REMIND, UH UH, MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
UH AND MY GOOD FRIEND, THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THAT OF COURSE. UH, THIS ACTION
IS SIMPLY THE FIRST STEP. IT'S
REDUCING THE SIZE OF THE DEFICIT
BY $17 BILLION. THAT IS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT. UH, WE DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE ANY ACTION UNTIL JUNE.
UH, WE HAVE DECIDED THAT WE WANT
TO TAKE ACTION NOW TO SHRINK THE AND THEN FOCUS ON
REDUCING IT COMPLETELY WILL DO
WHEN WE PASS A BALANCED BUDGET
IN JUNE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN I VOTE. THANK YOU SOONER
WINNERS ASKING FOR I VOTE.
SENATOR NILO IS ASKING FOR A NÓ
VOTE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HOW HØI I WROTE TO YOU.
HIY ARCHULETA, HØI ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD. HØI CABRIO. I CORTESI.
DELHI. NÓ DODD. RAO. HØI EGM. I
GLASER. GONZALES. BY GROWTH.
HURTADO. AYE, JONES. LAIRD. AYE,
LEMON. MCGUIRE I MANJAR AYE,
MEN. AYE, NEWMAN. I WIN. NÓ
NILO. NOW A CBO. NÓ, BUT UH,
IMPORTANT, TOO. IW IY RUBIO. èC
R TWO. RUBIO. I èC R TO NÓ
SKINNER. I SMALL QUOTAS. HØI
STERN. I HUMBERG WILL HAVE AYE.
WIENER. I WILL. NÓ PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. B. ATKINS.
BECKER. CORTES. AYE. GLASER.
GROWTH. JONES. HUMBER. ICE 27
NOSE SIX. THE MOTION CARRIES NOW
MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WERE NOW SENATE SECOND READING.
WE HAVE A FEW ITEMS, SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 144
WITH AMENDMENTS 1034 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1427 WITH AMENDMENTS
1441 WITH AMENDMENTS 1150 TO 96
1127 1408 1458 2ND READING IS
DEAN MARETT. NOW WE'RE MOVING
SENATE THIRD READING. AND WE
HAVE ONE ITEM. F ITEM. 35
SENATOR. SECRETARY PLEASE RE IN
A CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 127 BY
SENATOR WAHAB RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S EQUAL PAYDAY. SOONER
WE'LL HAVE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT S¼
èC R 127 EQUAL PAY DAY AFTER
MORE THAN 60 YEARS SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE FEDERAL EQUAL PAY
ACT OF 1963 WOMEN, ESPECIALLY
WOMEN OF COLOR CONTINUE TO
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
UNEQUAL PAY. A LIFETIME OF LOWER
PAY MEANS WOMEN HAVE LESS INCOME
TO SAVE FOR RETIREMENT AND LESS
INCOME COUNTED IN A SOCIAL
SECURITY OR PENSION BENEFIT
FORMULA, ACCORDING TO THE 2020.
REPORT ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS IN CALIFORNIA OVER 40
YEAR CAREER. THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT CALIFORNIA WOMEN
EARN AND WHAT WHITE MEN EARN
COST THE AVERAGE WHITE WOMAN.
$731,000 AN ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN
, $737,000, A BLACK WOMAN. $1.6
MILLION AND 2.1 MILLION FOR A
LATINA. FAIR PAY AND IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD STRENGTHEN THE
SECURITY OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES TODAY, REGARDLESS OF
EDUCATION, OR SOCIO-ECONOMIC
STATUS WHILE ENHANCING OUR
STATEWIDE ECONOMY MARCH 12TH
REPRESENTED THE DAY IN 2024 WHEN
THE WAGES PAID TO WOMEN CATCH UP
TO THE WAGES PAID TO MALES FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR NATIONWIDE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT EVERY
INDUSTRY DO BETTER TO CLOSE THIS
WAGE GAP AND ENSURE WOMEN ARE
PAID EQUALLY FOR EQUAL WORK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION, AND I NOTE SO
VERY COMMONLY, I'M STANDING AND
I AM TODAY, STANDING AS CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS, AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE GENDER EQUITY
ISSUES. BUT LET ME TALK ABOUT IT
FROM A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE,
AND OUR COLLEAGUE ADDRESSED THIS
IN HER COMMENTS AROUND THE
IMPACT ECONOMICALLY TO THE STATE
. I THINK MOST OF US WHO ARE
FOLLOWING THE DATA ON THE RISE
OF THE NUMBER OF UNHOUSED
PEOPLE. WE'RE SEEING THAT THE
LARGEST PERCENT. IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS HAS BEEN PEOPLE
OVER 55. AND ALARMINGLY THAT HAS
INCLUDED LARGE NUMBERS OF WOMEN.
IT'S STILL A HIGHER PERCENT
RIGHT NOW OF MEN, BUT OF THAT
OVER 55 YEAR OLD HOMELESS
INCREASE. A GOOD 40% ARE WOMEN.
SO HO! HOW DO WE GET TO THAT
POINT WHERE WE SEE WOMEN AT THE
POINT WHERE THEY YOU KNOW WHERE
IF THEY'VE WORKED AND THEN UH,
THE 40 YEARS AS THE OUR
COLLEAGUES DESCRIBED THAT THEY
WOULD BE THEN UNABLE TO PAY
RENT. PARTLY BECAUSE IF THIS
AVERAGE DIFFERENCE IN THAT
LIFETIME OF PAY HAD THEY BEEN
ABLE TO SAY, FOR EXAMPLE, ON A
401 Kò SO WE'RE TALKING 731,000
AND THAT WERE TO BE COMPOUNDED.
THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE FACING
HOMELESSNESS TODAY. AND YET
WE'RE THEN HAVING WE, THE STATE
AND ALL OF OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE HAVING TO COVER THE COST FOR
THEM AS THEY ARE UNSHELTERED, SO
THIS HAS REAL ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS AND I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE REV. RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
UH, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THIS
SENATE FLOOR I RICE ALSO IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR TO THIS
RESOLUTION AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
, UM AS I'VE LOOKED AROUND THE
SEOR, UM THROUGHOUT THE YEARS,
UH, I SEE HOW WE CONTINUE TO
INCH SLOWLY TOWARDS PARITY. AND
AS WE KNOW, POSSIBLY NEXT YEAR,
WE'LL HAVE 50% ON THIS FLOOR.
AND SO IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT
WOMEN JUST AS HARD DO THE SAME
WORK AND DESERVE TO GET PAID THE
SAME IN EVERY SECTOR IN OUR
SOCIETY. IT'S ALREADY BEEN, UM,
SHARED HOW MUCH WOMEN BRING TO
THE NOT ONLY TO THE TABLE TO
THIS ECONOMY, AND ACCORDING TO
THE UNITED STATES, CENSUS, WOMEN
WHO WORK FULL TIME STILL MAKE
ONLY 84 CENTS. UH, FOR EVERY
DOLLAR A MAN GETS PAID AND THE
WAGE GAP FOR WOMEN OF COLOR IS
EVEN GREATER. UH SO I JUST SAY
TO ALL OF US, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
AND NEED TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN
GET PAID WHAT THEY DESERVE EQUAL
PAY WILL LEAD TO STRONGER
FAMILIES AND STRONGER ECONOMY
FOR ALL OF US, AND AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR, I URGE ALL OF US TO
VOTE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE? SEEN NONE. SENATOR.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. UM I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. I SPECIFICALLY
ALSO WANT TO STATE AS THE FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
THAT WE CONSISTENTLY SAY WE ALSO
NEED TO DO BETTER AND TREAT
EVERYBODY EQUALLY. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FALL ITEM 35. ALLEN. AYE. I
RODE G. HØI ARCHULETA. BY ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR BY
BRADFORD. AYE, CABALLERO. I,
CORTEZ. BY DALLY. HØI DODD. AYE,
THE RAO HØI AGIN. AYE. BLAZER.
GONZALEZ, HØI GROVE. IY HURTADO.
I. JONES. LAYERED HØI LI. HØI
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENJIVAR. AYE,
MEN. HØI NEWMAN. AY WIN. HØI
NILO. BY OBO. I WOULDN'T YOU
KNOW. AYE, ROD. HØI RUBIO. I SAY
ART TO I. SKINNER. HØI SMALL
CUEVAS. AY STERN HØI HAMBERG
WAHHAB. AYE, WIENER. AYE WOKE.
AYE. IY 34 NOS. ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. NOW
MEMBERS. IT'S TIME FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS AT THIS
TIME, SENATOR MR VÀ. MR THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGETS ARE
COMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL WILL
MEET 15 MINUTES AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM 12 UNDER EIGHT.
SUB-COMMITTEE NUMBER THREE WILL
MEET 15 MINUTES AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM 1200, SENATOR LÀ. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE. NUMBER ONE ON
EDUCATION WILL MEET IN ROOM 2115
MINUTES AFTER THE CLOSE OF
SESSION. SUB COMMITTEE. ONE WILL
MEET IN ROOM 2115 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION, SENATOR PADILLA. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE. NUMBER FOUR ON
STATE GOVERNMENT ADMINISTRATION
WILL CONVENE 15 MINUTES
FOLLOWING SESSION IN ROOM 100
THREE HERE IN THE CAPITOL. ALL
RIGHT. AND SUBCOMITTEE FOUR
WE'LL MEET IN ROOM 113 HERE IN
THE CAPITOL 15 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION, SEE NÓ MORE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. OH, SENATOR
GONZALEZ. OK, ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. NOW
WE RETURN. WELL, I THOUGHT WE
DID, SENATOR GONZALEZ. AND
ACKNOWLEDGED AND ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH,
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
IN THE MATTY LOUNGE. THANK YOU.
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING SESSION IN THE MADDIE
LOUNGE. NOW MEMBERS WILL RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW
IS THE TIME FOR A JOURNEY OF
MEMORIES. PLEASE WE NEED QUIET
IN THE CHAMBER OF GOING ASK YOU
TO TAKE YOUR SEATS. FIRST UP IS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU, UM,
MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I
RISE. VERY SADLY. ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF DAVID
ERENER. A FRIEND, A DECADES LONG
LABOR LEADER. ALSO THE SPOUSE OF
MY VERY CLOSE FRIEND AND MENTOR,
FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER DION
EINER, WHO IS WITH US ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. DAVID ER WAS A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE AND AN
EXCELLENT ORGANIZER FOR SOCIAL
JUSTICE. FOR DECADES, HE WAS A
LEADER IN THE BAY AREA LABOR
MOVEMENT. HE WAS THE FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SEIU 535
AND A MEMBER OF S¼ EIU
INTERNATIONAL'S EXECUTIVE BOARD.
HE DIED IN BERKELEY. JUST UH, A
FEW WEEKS AGO AT THE AGE OF 82.
HE WAS BORN IN CHICAGO AND GREW
UP THERE, AND HIS LIFE WAS
MARKED BY A STRONG SENSE OF
FAMILY AND THE JEWISH FAITH. IT
WAS IN THESE EARLY YEARS THAT
HIS PASSION FOR ACTIVISM AND
ADVOCACY TOOK ROOT. IN THE EARLY
SIXTIES, HE ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN JUST AS
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS
GETTING STARTED AND ACTIVE AND
HEATING UP. AND WHILE IN COLLEGE
, HE TRAVELED TO MONTGOMERY,
ALABAMA, WITH THE STUDENT
NONVIOLENT COORDINATING
COMMITTEE SNCC, WHERE THEY
ORGANIZED AND ASSISTED DIRECT
ACTION CHALLENGES TO SEGREGATION
, RACISM AND POLITICAL
EXCLUSION. IN MONTGOMERY DAVID
WAS ARRESTED AND JAILED WITH
OTHER SNCC ACTIVISTS, WHICH
CULMINATED IN A HUNGER STRIKE
WHILE HE WAS IN JAIL. HE
GRADUATED FROM MICHIGAN WITH A
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK, AND HE
CONTINUED HIS JOURNEY AS A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER, HAVING BEEN
TRAINED AND INSPIRED BY THE WELL
KNOWN ACTIVIST SAUL LINSKEY, WHO
SOME OF YOU MAY NOT, UH, RECALL,
BUT MAYBE YOU RECALL HIS BOOK
RULES FOR RADICALS. IN 1966
DAVID MOVED TO BERKELEY AND SOON
BECAME ACTIVE IN THE EAST BAY
LABOR SCENE. HE BEGAN WORKING
FOR S¼ EIU LOCAL 3535, WHERE HE
FOCUSED ON ORGANIZING. SOCIAL
WORKERS, NURSES AND MENTAL
HEALTH WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE
SOON AFTER. DAVID AND DION MET
DION WAS THEN ALSO ACTIVE IN
EAST BAY LABOR CIRCLES. THE TWO
FELL IN LOVE, MARRIED AND HAD
TWO CHILDREN, JOSH AND DANIELLE.
DAVID EVENTUALLY SERVED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF 535, AND
HE GREW THE MEMBERSHIP BY THREE
100% HE WAS APPOINTED TO THE S¼
èC IU INTERNATIONAL EXECUTIVE
BOARD BY THEN PRESIDENT JOHN
SWEENEY, WHO WAS LATER PRESIDENT
OF A FL èC. I Ó DAVID WAS A
TRADE UNIONIST. THROUGH AND
THROUGH. HE WALKED PICKET LINES
FOR ANY NUMBER OF UNIONS OVER
THE YEARS, AND HE WAS SO
COMMITTED TO THE PURPOSE OF THE
STRIKE OR WHATEVER OTHER
ACTIVITY HE WAS INVOLVED IN. IN
DIRECT ACTION ACTIVITY HE WOULD
HANG IN UNTIL ARRESTED. AND HE
LANDED HIMSELF IN JAIL NUMEROUS
TIMES IN THE NAME OF JUSTICE.
AND IN THE SEARCH FOR EQUITY AND
RESPECT FOR NOT ONLY OUR WORKERS
, BUT ALSO FOR OUR SISTERS AND
BROTHERS OF COLOR AND OTHERS.
OUR MUTUAL FRIEND AND FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM BATES.
DESCRIBED DAVID AS A PERSON WHO
TRULY BELIEVED IN UNIONS AND
THEIR COLLECTIVE POWER. AND
TOM'S SPOUSE, MY GOOD FRIEND AND
FORMER STATE SENATOR LONNIE
HANCOCK CALLED DAVID, A GREAT,
INNOVATIVE UNION LEADER AND A
VISIONARY. FOR THE 25TH
ANNIVERSARY OF LOCAL 535 DAVID
DEVELOPED A CULTURAL EVENT THAT
FEATURED HARLEM RENAISSANCE
ARTIST JACOB LAWRENCE AND FOLK
SINGER UTAH PHILLIPS. HE LOVED
ALL TYPES OF MUSIC, BUT
ESPECIALLY MUSIC FROM THE
TWENTIES, THIRTIES AND FORTIES.
BUT HE ALSO LOVED CLASSICAL
MUSIC, AND HE AND DION WERE VERY
STRONG PATRONS OF THE OAKLAND
SYMPHONY. BUT HE HAD A SPECIAL
AFFINITY FOR PAUL ROBESON, THE
LEGENDARY ACTOR, SINGER AND
POLITICAL ACTIVIST. AND IN 1998
DAVID ORGANIZED A BAY AREA
COMMITTEE TO CELEBRATE THE 100TH
BIRTHDAY OF PAUL ROBESON. BUT
MORE RECENTLY, AND THIS WAS, YOU
KNOW, NOT THAT MANY YEARS BEFORE
HE DIED, DAVID APPROACHED THEN
OAKLAND SYMPHONY DIRECTOR
MICHAEL MORGAN TO COMMISSION AN
ORIGINAL COMPOSITION JUST
FOCUSED ON ROBISON. SADLY MORGAN
HIMSELF PASSED AWAY BEFORE THE
PREMIERE OF THAT PIECE. TITLED
HERE I STAND. AND THAT PIECE WAS
PERFORMED BY THE OAKLAND
SYMPHONY EARLIER THIS YEAR. AND
THAT PERFORMANCE WAS DAVID'S
LAST OUTING BEFORE HE DIED.
WHICH BY THE WAY, THAT PIECE
HERE I STAND WILL ALSO BE
PREMIERED NEXT YEAR AT THE
KENNEDY CENTER IN WASHINGTON, Dð
èC SO, DION, WHO IS ON THE
FLOOR WITH US TODAY, SAID OF THE
OAKLAND SYMPHONY PERFORMANCE. IT
WAS FABULOUS. IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
PERFORMANCE. DAVID LOVED IT. AND
IT WAS REALLY THE LAST TIME THAT
HE WENT OUT OF THE HOUSE.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. DAVID WAS
ALSO A FOODIE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
BEING A LONGTIME BERKELEY
RESIDENT. HE ENJOYED COOKING AND
HE AND DION WERE FIXTURES IN OUR
VIBRANT RESTAURANT SCENE. THEY
ALSO LOVE TO TRAVEL AND WE AVID
PARTICIPANTS IN THE HOUSE
EXCHANGE. UH YOU KNOW, IN THAT
PROGRAM WHERE YOU ALLOW VISITORS
TO STAY IN YOUR HOUSE, AND YOU
ARE THEN ABLE TO STAY IN THEIR
HOUSE WHETHER YOU'RE GOING TO
ITALY, FRANCE, GERMANY, YOU NAME
IT. UM AND SO THEY WENT ON MANY
LONG TRIPS AND DID THOSE HOUSE
EXCHANGES, BUT DAVID'S REAL
PASTIME WAS FISHING. AND WHEN
HE'S WHEN HIS CHILDREN WERE
YOUNGER, THEY OFTEN WENT CAMPING
AND FISHING, TAKING LONG ROAD
TRIPS TO TODD, THE GRAND TETONS,
COLORADO, AND HE WOULD SEARCH
FOR THE BEST CAMPING SPOT. WHERE
HE COULD FISH. SO, IN ADDITION
TO DION AND HIS CHILDREN,
DANIELLE AND, UH, JOSH DAVID ER
SURVIVED BY THREE SIBLINGS AND
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN. HE WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED BY HIS FAMILY,
HIS MANY FRIENDS IN BERKELEY AND
BEYOND HIS IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND THE COMMUNITIES
HE SERVED WILL BE REMEMBERED, AS
WILL HIS TIRELESS DEDICATION TO
CREATING A MORE JUST AND
EQUITABLE SOCIETY. SO I ASK YOU
TO ADJOURN IN DAVID A'S MEMO.
THANK YOU. OUR DEEPEST SENATE
CONDOLENCES TO THIS AMAZING
LEADER, LABOR LEADER ACTIVIST
AND WE WELCOME LEGISLATURE HERE
TODAY WITH US AND WE ASK THAT
YOU BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO HE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
PICTURE NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE WILL
CONTINUE WITH OUR JOURNEY OF
MEMORIES. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UH, AND GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF ISIDORE HALL, JUNIOR.
A BELOVED PATRIARCH AND LONGTIME
LOS ANGELES RESIDENT WHO IS THE
FATHER OF FORMER CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
SENATOR ISADORE HALL. THE THIRD
BORN IN NEW ORLEANS IN 1942, MR.
HALL ATTENDED TIM TET ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN BALI HIGH SCHOOL IN
WEST MONROE, LOUISIANA.
EMANCIPATED AT AGE 14 HE, LIKE
MANY FROM LOUISIANA CAME WEST.
HE BEGAN TAKING CARE OF HIS
BROTHERS AND HIS SISTERS WHO
LOOK UP TO HIM IN AFFECTIONATELY
CALLED HIM UNCLE BROTHER BECAUSE
OF HIS INFLUENCE ON THEIR
UPBRINGING AND HIS ROLE IN THEIR
LIVES. 1967 HE MOVED WITH HIS
FAMILY TO LOS ANGELES, WHERE HE
EVENTUALLY LANDED JOBS AT
SAFEWAY AND VAUGHN'S GROCERY
STORES. AND WAS RECOGNIZED AS A
HARD WORKER WHO HAD A LONG TIME
COMMITMENT TO THIS INDUSTRY,
WHERE HE RETIRED, UH, IN A
MANAGEMENT POSITION AFTER 41
YEARS OF SERVICE, RECEIVING
SEVERAL AWARDS FOR HIS
OUTSTANDING JOB, PERFORMANCE AND
LEADERSHIP. A LOVER OF JAZZ AND
RHYTHM AND BLUES. MR HALL WAS
KNOWN FOR HIS OUTGOING
PERSONALITY AND INFECTIOUS SMILE
. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR GENEROUSLY GIVING
HIS TIME AND FINANCIAL MEANS TO
ASSIST OTHERS IN THEIR
ENDEAVORS. HE WAS A DEDICATED
FATHER AND MR HALL OFTEN TAUGHT
HIS CHILDREN TO HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THE WORLD THROUGH
THEIR ACTIONS AND THEIR VOICE.
HIS ALTRUISTIC PHILOSOPHY
RESONATED WITH HIS CHILDREN,
INSPIRING HIS SON, ISIDORE TO
RUN FOR PUBLIC OFFICE AND TO
HELP SERVE AND UPLIFT
CALIFORNIANS. MR HALL WAS A
FOUNDATION. IN HIS LIFE AND IN
THE LIVES OF SO MANY HE LEAVES
BEHIND HIS WIFE, MARGARET HALL,
A SON AND THREE DAUGHTERS, UH
AND NINE STEPCHILDREN AND 14
GRANDCHILDREN. 18 GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE GREAT
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. WE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE OFFER
OUR HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO MR
HALL'S FAMILY AND ALL OF THOSE
WHO WERE TOUCHED BY HIS LIFE AND
HIS IMPACT IN LOS ANGELES. AND
WITH THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. IN THE SENATE,
CONDOLENCES TO THE HALL FAMILY
AND ASK THAT YOU BRING THE NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
DALLY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF LOU CONOR WHO WE
ACTUALLY HAD HERE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR LAST JULY. 11TH HE WAS THE
102 YEAR OLD LAST SURVIVING, UM,
MEMBER OF THE, UH HE HE HE LET
ME JUST LET ME READ THIS AND DO
A LITTLE BETTER JOB HERE. HE
DIED APRIL 1ST FROM CONGESTIVE
HEART FAILURE. HE RESIDES IN
GRASS VALLEY IN THE FIRST
SENATE-DISTRICT. UM WE
RECOGNIZED HIM ON JULY 11TH OF
LAST YEAR, LOU WAS THE ON THE U.
S¼ S¼, ARIZONA WHEN IT WAS HIT
IN PEARL HARBOR, WHERE 177 DIED.
HE WAS THE LAST LIVING
SURVIVING, UH, SAILOR ON THAT
SHIP. THERE WAS THREE. 135
SURVIVED THE ATTACK. LOU WORKED
HARD TO SAVE AS MANY SAILORS AS
HE COULD. HE ALSO SERVED IN THE
KOREAN WAR AND THE VIETNAM WAR.
HE ATTENDED FLIGHT SCHOOL SHOT
DOWN TWICE DURING HIS DUTY
ESCAPED SHARKS. UH HE FLEW THE
PB Y FLYING SEAPLANES, UH, HE
HELPED SAVED OVER 200.
AUSTRALIAN COAST WATCHERS. UH,
HELPED DEVELOP THE SARS SYSTEMS.
WHEN YOU GET SHOT DOWN, YOU
LEARN HOW TO SURVIVE. UM HE ALSO
MET WITH PRESIDENT KENNEDY. UH,
HIS. HE WAS A REALLY JUST A
HUMBLE TEAM PLAYER. IF YOU GUYS
REMEMBER LAST YEAR WHEN LOU WAS
HERE, UH, HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS,
UH, DAUGHTER, LEANNE, HIS SON,
TONY, HIS STEPSON, RON, AND MANY
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. UH, LOU WILL BE
LAID TO REST IN, UM, GRASS
VALLEY WITH NEXT TO HIS LATE
WIFE, VALERIE, WHO DIED IN 2016,
WHO HAD BEEN MARRIED FOR 45
YEARS. UH, I GAVE YOU THE
MEMBERS LAST YEAR. A BOOK? UM, I
HOPE YOU GOT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
READ THE BOOK ABOUT LOU'S LIFE
OF INCREDIBLE STORY. UH WE LOST
ONE OF THE REAL TRUE AMERICAN
HEROES WHO DID SO MUCH FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND JUST WAS SO HUMBLE
IN THE WAY HE DID IT. UM SO, UM,
THE FIRST SENATE-DISTRICT WILL
GREATLY MISS HIM. I WANNA THANK
ALL THE VETERANS THAT SERVE ON
THIS THAT THAT ARE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. I. I NAMED HIM OFF
LAST YEAR AND I I'M GONNA DO IT
AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK THAT, UH,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE FREEDOMS WE
HAVE TODAY. IF IT WASN'T FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED AND WE
HAVE SENATOR ARCHULETA, SENATOR
GRO SENATOR AGMON SENATOR
MENJIVAR, SENATOR ROTH, SENATOR
UN BEG AND SENATOR NEWMAN AND WE
ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OTHERS WHO'VE
SERVED, UH JEFF, WHO TAKES THE
VIDEO OR PICTURES HERE AND, UH,
BERNIE, SO I WANNA THANK YOU ALL
. UH AND JUST RECOGNIZE YOU
BECAUSE LOU WAS THAT HUMBLE
LEADER, UH AND DID A LOT FOR OUR
COUNTRY AND, UH, HE WILL SURELY
BE MISSED, BUT HE DID LIVE A
WONDERFUL GREAT LIFE. I MEAN TO
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO WALK
IN HERE AT 100 AND ONE LAST YEAR
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION. SO, UM,
HE'LL BE GREATLY TO THE FAMILY.
WE LOVE YOU, UM AND WE'LL TRY TO
MAKE IT OUT TO THE SERVICES. SO
MR PRESIDENT, I REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF LOU
CONT A GREAT AMERICAN HERO.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MANAR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, AND I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
BIEBER FOR BRINGING LOU'S NAME
THAT WE MAY RECOGNIZE HIM. I
ACTUALLY READ THE ENTIRE BOOK
YOU GAVE ME LAST YEAR. AND IN
FACT, UM, EVERYWHERE I WENT LAST
YEAR FOR VETERANS DAY EVENTS. I
SPOKE ABOUT HIM AND HIS STORY
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL, FUN FACT,
HE GOT MARRIED IN MY DISTRICT IN
VAN NUYS. UM HE WAS VERY CLOSE
FRIENDS WITH SHIRLEY TEMPLE. UH,
GROWING UP. UM AND THE FACT THAT
AFTER HE WOULD GET DISCHARGED
AND HE WOULD GET CALLED BACK AND
HE NEVER HESITATED. AND HE GOT
BACK IN. I THINK TWO MORE TIMES,
AND IT COST HIM SOME SOME THINGS
PERSONALLY RELATIONSHIPS, BUT HE
WAS ALWAYS PUTTING COUNTRY FIRST
, UM, IN THE BOOK. IT SPOKE
ABOUT WHAT HE INTERNALIZED AND
STUCK IN HIS MIND AND PUT IN HIS
MIND WHEN HE WAS IN THE WATER
BEING CIRCLED BY SHARKS, AND
WHEN HE WAS, UM ABOUT TO BE
CAPTURED, AND THE THINGS HE PUT
TOGETHER FOR OTHER FUTURE P Ó W
S¼. AND I THINK ABOUT THOSE
LESSONS DAY IN DAY OUT NOW I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN,
SENATOR, UH, HE LIVED IN AMAZING
LIFE. AMERICAN HERO AND WE WERE
ALWAYS REMEMBER LOU. THANK YOU
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THIS
AMERICAN HERALD AND SOLDIER AND
WE ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE'S NÓ
OTHER BUSINESS, SENATOR MCGUIRE
THE JUST IS CLEAR, MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
TODAY MEMBERS. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS.
COMING MONDAY, APRIL 8TH AT 2
P.M. HOPE EVERYONE HAS A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND BACK AT HOME
IN THEIR DISTRICTS. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE 30 PM, AT
WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WE RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AT 2 P.M.